Agnes alone is very good tournament  absolutely and uh so far like his wide  games here have been  uh aggressive very impressive yeah that  win against kukesh showing a  yeah and there there we have it uh  Magnus just putting stuff in the center  and uh yeah and uh probably saying I  just forgot Bishop D5 or whatever yeah  yeah that gesture the world towards the  the forehead was yeah  like what have I done there  and just one move and it was pretty much  gone beyond saving but yeah it was quite  difficult before that we've got to say  uh  certainly won the opening battle  okay wow big result all the standings  yeah we're gonna have to take in an  early lead here right because of the  people on plus one he might be the only  one winning today  uh Jing is unlikely to win  another